foreign
guys it's another installment of
flickers of fear doing some Christmas
movies this week obviously because
Christmas is later on this week so
2021's red snow
this was another movie that I came
across completely randomly uh I'll note
that there was another movie that was
called Red Snow that I think came out in
2019 but it's not this one that one
wasn't a horror movie I think it was
more like an action thriller type of
thing so don't get them confused uh but
yes this one came out in 2021 and this
was you know like I said I just came
across it randomly I was browsing
through some internet lists like looking
for best new Christmas horror movies
because I was looking for some different
ones like to review that I hadn't seen
so Red's now I went into it completely
blind as I usually like to do as I've
mentioned many times on this channel
before and I'm gonna say like I'm not
gonna lie like for the first few minutes
of the movie I thought that my sort of
cavalier movie choosing strategy was
going to end up biting me in the ass uh
that's only because I hadn't realized
that red snow was a a vampire movie
which I'm not like a huge fan of and B
set up almost like a supernatural
rom-com and kind of like playing out
similarly to that at first not exactly
but it had like that kind of vibe to it
but I stuck with it and I'm actually
like really glad I did because it ended
up being pretty delightful now don't go
into this expecting like a balls to the
wall like holiday bloodbath or anything
like that it definitely does go in a
more horrory Direction like in the third
act and it does have some gore and
things like that but it leans pretty
heavily into the comedy end of the scale
more than horror so just know that going
in so you won't go in like expecting
that it's going to be a slasher or
something like that because it's not so
red snow at least according to IMDb uh
seems to be the second feature length
effort from the writer director Sean
Nichols Lynch whose previous credit like
his uh first feature-length film that he
wrote and directed was called prep
school that came out in 2015 and he did
like a bunch of short films as well I
think he has another movie upcoming
although I will admit that I didn't
really recognize a lot of the actors
here um you know because this is like
fairly low budget but they all did like
a mostly great job particularly the two
leads who I really liked but one actor
that's in this that pretty much everyone
will immediately recognize is Vernon
Wells who has a small role in this movie
as like a vampire hunter type character
so Vernon Wells as pretty much every
movie nerd knows is an Australian
character actor who's been in which is
millions of things but is probably best
known known but he's like iconic for his
performances in the road warrior like
you know Mad Max 2 Weird Science uh and
as the legendary Bennett from the 1985
Arnold Schwarzenegger movie Commando so
this guy is uh is in it and he's
fantastic
um I kind of wish he'd been in it a bit
more but even his brief appearance is
wonderful I mean I love that guy and
he's great in this so this movie uh
premiered in August of 2021 at London
Fright Fest and it actually seemed to
like Garner a lot of positive Buzz as it
sort of made its way around the horror
festival film circuit uh you know and
got a bunch of awards like audience
Choice Awards and you know best actor
nods and things like that before it uh
ended up landing on several streaming
Platforms in December of 2021 uh as of
this recording you can watch the movie
for free I think on Voodoo and also on
Plex that would probably have
commercials and uh you can also watch it
for free if you have an Amazon Prime
subscription which I do so that's what I
watched it on so at the beginning of the
story were introduced to a young woman
named Olivia who's played by Denise
Cisneros and she's like obsessed with
vampires and she's also aspiring to be
like a vampire romance novelist type of
thing uh she hasn't been having too much
success in that regard though uh you
know because she has like a big drawer
full of rejection letters uh but she
seems kind of like determined you know
so for the first little bit of the movie
we're just kind of like watching her go
about her what seems to be like a very
quiet and isolated life she lives in
this sort of remote cabin uh in Lake
Tahoe which we find out later was like
left to her by her mother who only died
like a year or so previously so
Christmas is only a few days away
um so they kind of like measure the days
by her taking little candies out of her
little Advent calendar now Olivia does
seem like pretty content I mean she just
kind of Putters around this very cozy
cabin uh reading a book of vampire
stories which is a book that I just
called one I think it's called one 100
little vicious little vampire stories or
something which is a book that I also
own she has the hardback I have the
paperback I have a bunch of those series
they had them from they sold them at
Barnes and Noble I think but yeah so I
just kind of laughed when I saw it I was
like hey I have that book too but yeah
so that's kind of funny so she's like
reading that she's working on her novel
watching Nosferatu like on her laptop
the original silent one or you know
drinking peppermint tea by the Christmas
tree which is actually decorated with a
bunch of plastic vampire fangs so like I
said she's really really into vampires
now like I said she does seem kind of
like happy with her life but we sense
that she might be maybe just like a
little bit lonely
um she talks to her sister like you
never see the sister in the movie but
she talks to her on the phone a couple
times
um like her sister who's married and has
three kids
kind of calls her on the phone and it's
like oh I think it's really unhealthy
for you to isolate yourself up there
especially during the holidays like you
know you're you know my kids miss you
and all this other kind of stuff so
maybe you should you know not squirrel
yourself away up there now we as the
audience already know that there are
some vampire Shenanigans afoot because
we've seen a trio of vampires it kind of
in action like out in the woods
presumably close to where this cabin is
uh Olivia though obviously is clueless
to the danger until one night when a
wounded little bat uh slams into the
window of her cabin now she's a little
squicked out or like a little afraid of
it but you know it's a bat she loves
vampires and she's you know she loves
animals presumably so she just gingerly
like Scoops up the little fella and puts
him in a shoebox uh giving him some
water and you know tending his wound
with like a little teeny Band-Aid which
I thought was really funny so she leaves
the bat in the shoe box like in the
garage overnight imagine her surprise
then when she walks into the garage
hours the next morning to find an
attractive and very naked man uh lying
on the floor in the midst of all these
torn like cardboard remnants of the
shoebox that he you know clearly busted
out of uh he has like a pretty nasty
looking wound in his side and when he
kind of turns around to look at her it's
immediately clear that he is a creature
of the night he's got the white eyes
he's got fangs he's got the deathly
power the whole deal now Olivia is
obviously freaked out by this but um
recovers her a plum like fairly quickly
uh she loves vampires remember and she
is like super jacked to find out that
vampires are actually real and she has
one in her garage so she brings the
vampire uh who eventually reveals that
his name is Luke he's played by Nico
Bellamy uh she brings him some clothes
uh all she has is women's clothes
because it's from like her mom's it's
her mom's old stuff so for a long time
like this supposedly like scary creature
of the night is wearing like you know
kind of like a dress and a like old lady
clothes you know what I mean
um and she also goes to the butcher shop
and brings back little tubs of like
Pig's blood for him to drink like so his
wounds can heal up because like I said
he's been wounded uh she even this is
very funny I don't know why I thought
this was so funny but um she even goes
so far as to like heat the blood up in
the microwave like in a mug like tea and
she like brings it to him on a tray like
it's all very Gentile and it's like that
kind of cracks me up now he does
complain that the pig's blood is gross
like you know just it's nothing compared
to like human blood but you know despite
all the grumbling he does actually seem
grateful for her help because he's
actually too weak to go back out into
the world on his own so Olivia who like
I said is very excited uh she
immediately just starts applying Luke
with questions about like you know the
vampire rules she's like you know all
the different fictional vampires like
have all these different rules so what
are the real ones you know like can you
walk around in the daytime or are you
bothered by crosses or garlic or
something like that so Luke is initially
kind of like scoffs at her like thinking
she's kind of naive and she's being like
really she's all like ooh like you know
wondrous and he's just like uh okay
whatever but eventually like over time
he kind of starts to warm to her a
little bit and starts kind of telling
her what she wants to know now she does
actually allow him to stay in the garage
but she sort of like locks him in there
at night because she can't quite trust
and like Vamp out on her like while
she's sleeping he claims he tells her
that he doesn't actually kill people he
just drinks some of their blood and
leaves them alive but she isn't really
sure if she believes this you know she
just met the guy after all so she's like
well you can stay out here locked in the
garage until until I can trust you you
know meanwhile uh a man named Julius
King who is the aforementioned Vernon
Wells he turns up on her doorstep not
too long after Luke's arrival claiming
that he's a private investigator
um on the trail of three very dangerous
criminals uh one of which of course is
Luke
so Olivia even though she's you know
just met him really she actually covers
for Luke but Julius is pretty suspicious
that Olivia knows more about this than
she's letting on so he decides he's
gonna remain in the area and just kind
of like you know stay like lay low for a
little while and just like watch and see
what it develops Luke's other two
vampire companions uh it should also be
noted are also lurking around in the
woods keeping an eye on Luke from afar
like as he recovers in the care of this
new human friend that he has acquired so
for a while as I mentioned earlier the
movie plays out almost like a
supernatural rom-com like a you know
like a comedic kind of uh situation it's
a ridiculous situation but it's kept
pretty low-key but it's still like kind
of funny you know and you have the whole
thing where this where Luke who's a
vampire and he's initially like very
Gruff and pissy and everything like that
but he slowly kind of starts to soften
toward her and is ultimately kind of
Charmed by her enthusiasm like about
finding out that vampires are real and
her like being willing to defra to
defend him and like you know things like
that so it appears uh you know as the
movie goes on that the two of them might
be developing something of a romance
um and it comes to a point too where
Luke actually reads uh Olivia's novel
that she's working on like her
manuscript which is very cringingly
titled touched by a vampire and uh he
starts to like give her encouragement
about it but he also gives her like a
lot of constructive criticism about like
how she can improve it so I have to say
like the best aspects of the movie are
the interactions between like Olivia and
Luke they're funny and like sort of
sweet but they're also kind of like
tinged with you know just this very
perilous uncertainty right because you
know for example Luke tells Olivia that
Julius King the guy that came looking
for him is a vampire hunter who works
for this very shady like almost like
quasi-fascist organization and their
mission is to wipe out every magical
creature on earth like unicorns and [ __ ]
like that
um including the sadly now extinct candy
elves and he's like yeah they're as cool
as they sound you know what I mean so
it's like that made me laugh out loud
um and he also says that Julius was the
one that shot him like at the beginning
of the movie like like I said because he
was a wounded Batman like against the
window and that he had used like a
crossbow that was dipped in holy water
so that's why it wounded him so badly
and again like Luke claims that I don't
really kill people I just drink blood
from them and he makes what sounds like
the very reasonable point it's like hey
if I had to murder people every night to
feed like I'd be leaving corpses
scattered all over the west coast and
like people would start to notice right
but the thing about it that's really
good about this is how much of what he
tells Olivia is true how much of what
Julius King tells her is true like how
much is Luke maybe playing into
Olivia's romantic fantasies about
vampires in order to you know get his
own needs met he obviously needs
somewhere to hold up he needs somebody
that's going to defend him he needs
somebody who's going to help him until
he's healthy enough to go back out on
his own and stuff like that so maybe
he's just like stringing her along and
what exactly is going to happen too when
Olivia you know to her kind of like
again romantic Notions about vampires
when the Vampire Hunter and possibly
Luke's Undead companions like inevitably
come calling or come to get him so this
was actually like a pretty fun little
movie um I'm not usually as I mentioned
a big fan of vampire movies with some
exceptions to that of course or of
horror comedies with like more of a
rom-com kind of edge but this one is
actually like pretty lovable
um and definitely went like in a more
gory horror Direction toward the end of
it
um it was really difficult like not to
like Olivia's character um she was very
like nerdy and very Earnest and she was
genuinely so excited like meeting a real
live vampire and it that kind of made
you it was like really infectious like
it made you kind of excited about it too
like because she was so excited and uh
and Luke is really like the perfect foil
to that he's just kind of like playing
the sort of like reluctant love interest
uh sort of character and he plays that
really well
um I have to say I didn't really love
the other two vampires uh whose names
are Jackie and Brock uh they're played
by Laura Kennon and Alan Silva
respectively I thought they were a
little bit too like over the top and a
little bit try hard like they were
trying too hard to be like you know me
and vampires I like to like like that
and I thought they went slightly too far
in that direction but I didn't really
mind it all that much um because really
their appearance sort of like signals
the start of the third act which is a
lot more bloody and gory and more horror
based you know so you know if you like
Christmas set horror comedies and in
particular want to see one that kind of
like gently skewers the whole vampires
as romantic Heroes kind of true rope and
it did go in some directions I didn't
quite expect then this one I think
though will probably like nicely fit the
bill besides that it has kind of like a
really nice cozy very snowy holiday Vibe
which was you know really appealing for
this time of year don't expect an out
and out horror film though um it like I
mentioned it unspools mostly is kind of
like a horror tinged romantic comedy for
about the two-thirds the first two
thirds of it
um in tone as a matter of fact it kind
of reminded me a little bit of the 2016
movie colossal that I talked about on
this series a while back you know that
the one where Anne Hathaway was in it
she was an alcoholic and her actions
like controlled the Rampages of like a
Kaiju like on in Tokyo or something like
that so the tone of that was kind of
similar like the humor of that was kind
of similar even though red snow is much
bloodier and more overtly horror than
colossal was but this sense of humor is
kind of similar so if you liked colossal
then you might like red snow as well so
you know just Brew up some peppermint
tea and uh maybe give it a spot on your
your Christmas horror rotation give it a
shot and if you do let me know what you
thought about it in the comments and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear and I'll see you guys again on the
next one bye